(manifestations)rererererererere
Downing Street du parlement,
ququques manifestants qui n'ont
pas de bons mots à l'endroit
de leur dirigeant.eaeaeaeaeaeaep
de choses négativespoint de vue,
mais j'ai jamais imaginé
que c'était à ce point-la a a a:
des rassemblements arrosés
à la résidence du premier
ministre, alors qu'on demandait
aux Britanniquesrererererererer.
Boris Johnson n'a pas participé
à tous ces événements, mais
il a passé quelques dizaines
de minut
Dans le jardin de la résidence
en mai 202eseses participants
étaient invités à apporter
leurs propres consommations.
"Personne ne m'a dit que c'était
contre les règles", s'est-il
qu'il pensait participer
à une rencontre de aiaiail.
"C'est lui qui nt t t t t t t ts
quelles étaient les règles",
répond ce manifestant.
(brouhaha)
Une grogne qui s'est
enenenent faite sentir
dans les murs du Parlement.
L'opposition a bombardé q q q qs
et exigé sa démission.
"C'est une perte de temps",
répond Boris Johnson,gugugugugus
d'attendre encore un peu.
r r r rapport d'enquête sur
les fêtes à Downing Street
devrait être rendu publnenenene.
Si le premier ministre peut
toujours compter sur de fidèles
alliés, sur les banquettes
conservatrices,  bout de patien.
Un député a décidé de faire
défection pour rejoindre
les travaillistes. Un autre,
un vétérne s'est pas gêné pour e
sa manière de penser à son chef.
a-t-il lancé.
Un groupe d'élus tente même
de recueillir suffisamment
d'appui au f f f f f f f f f f e
d'un vote de confiance.
"S'ils continuent de perdre
les conservateurs n'hésiteront
ààààà remplacer leur chef",
croit cet universitaire.exexexen
a un chat qui a neuf vies.
"Le premier ministre en a perdu
que le politicien aguerri a déjà
écécécécécu à d'autres crises.
Le premier ministre a annoncé
mesures sanitaires, commeororors
lieux et la recommandation
de travailler de la maisoneseses
dès la semaine prochaine.
Une annonce importante, qui
n'a toutefois pas fait d'ombre
à la principale discussion
l'avenir de Boris Johnson.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair
Radio-Canada, à Londres